welcome back everyone hope you had a
good Thanksgiving these chairs here um
by the way not sure thanks awning not
sure you guys funny didn't use but in
reinforcement learning which had a lot
about robotics right then one of the you
know cost a problem lot of people use
reinforcement to solve is robotics and I
think back in May the insight Mars
Lander had launched from here in
California and is about to make an
attempt at landing on the planet Mars in
the next two and a half hours or so so
excited about that I think is actually
one of the grandest applications of
robotics because you know with what 20
minute life speed from Earth to Mars
you know once it starts this landing
there's nothing anyone on the earth can
do and so I think is actually one the
most exciting applications of a Tong's
robotics but you launched this thing is
now about 20 20 light minutes away from
Planet Earth so you actually can't
control it in real time and you just
have to hope like crazy that your
software works well enough but land on
this planet you know and stuff well
we'll find out a little bit afternoon if
the landing have been successfully or
longer as you know III think um sir I
just get excited about stuff like this I
hope you guys do too and but they'll see
they're from California I mean take some
pride that it launched from my home
state of California and it's now nearing
is uh landing on Mars alright so um what
I want to do today is continue our
discussion on reinforcement learning do
a quick recap of the MDP or the Markov
decision process framework and then
we'll start to talk about algorithms for
solving them DPS in particular need to
define something called the value
function which tells you how good it is
to be in different states of the MDP and
then we'll define the value function and
then talk about an algorithm called
Valley iteration for computing the value
function and this will help us figure
out how to actually find a good control
or a finally good policy for them DP and
it will wrap up with learning state
transition probabilities and how to put
alson together
into an actual reinforcement learning
algorithm that you can implement to
recap our motivating example run the
example from the last time from before
Thanksgiving was this 11 state MVP and
we said that an MDP comprises a five
tuple list of five things with States so
that example had 11 States actions and
in this example the actions were the
compass direction north south east and
west we can try to go in each of the
four compass directions the state
transition probabilities and example if
the robot attempts to go north
it has 80% chance of heading north and
0.1% chance of viewing off to the left
and the point one chance of veering off
to the right gamma is a number slightly
less than one usually say less than one
there's a discount factor think of the
0.99 and R is the reward function that
helps us specify where we want the robot
to end up and so what we said last time
was that the way an MDP works is you
start up in some state as zero honestly
better you choose an action a zero and
as a result of that it transitions the
new state s 1 which is drawn according
to p FS 0 a 0 and then you choose a new
action a 1 and as a result the MDP
transition system new state PF s 1 a 1
and the total payoff is the sum of
rewards and the goal is to come up with
a way and formally that goes to come
over policy pi which is a mapping from
the states to the actions that will tell
you how to choose actions from whatever
state you're in so that the policy
maximizes the expected value of the
total payoff ok
and so I think lost time I I kind of
claimed that this is the optimal policy
for this MVP and what this means for
example is if you look at this state but
this policy is telling you that fire 3
comma 1 equals West I guess oh you can
write west or left or what do you call
that left arrow right we're from the
state from the state 3 1 you know the
best action to take this to go left us
to go west and so if you're executing
this policy what that means is that on
every step the action you choose would
be you know PI right of the of the state
that you're in
ok so what I'd like to do is now define
the value function so how did I come up
with this right what I like to do is
have you learn given an MDP given this
five tuple how do you compute the octal
policy and one of the challenges with
finding the optimal policy is that you
know there's a there's an exponentially
large number of possible policies right
if you have eleven states and four
actions per state the number of possible
policies is four to the power of 11
which is not that Bay because 11 is a
small MDP right this is the number of
policies possible policies for an MTP is
combinatorially large is a number of
actions the power a number of states so
how do you find the best policy so what
you learned today is how to compute the
auto policy now in order to develop an
algorithm for computing an auto policy
we'll need to define three things so
just as a roadmap what I'm about to do
is define V PI V Star and PI star okay
and based on these definitions will see
that will come to definition
derived that pi-star is the auto policy
okay but so let's let's go through these
few definitions first V PI so for a
policy PI V PI is a function mapping
from States to the rails is such that V
PI of s is the expected total payoff for
starting and state that's executing PI
and so sometimes you write this as V PI
of s is the expected
well total payoff given that you execute
the policy PI and the initial state as 0
is equal to s so the definition of a V
PI this is called the value function for
a policy this is called the value
function for the policy PI ok and so
what the value function for a policy PI
denoted be pious is it tells you for any
state you might start it there's a
function mapping of states the rewards
write for any say you might start saying
what's the expected total payoff if you
start off your robot in that state and
if you execute the policy PI and XC the
policy PI means take actions according
to the policy PI right so here's a
here's a specific example this policy so
let's consider the following policy PI
right
so this is now the great policy right
you're from some of these days it looks
like is heading to the minus one reward
oh sorry Segura the reward was plus one
we get here and technically this called
an absorbing state meaning that if you
ever get to the plus one to the minus
one then the world ends and then no more
rewards or penalties after that right so
but so there's actually not a very good
policy so policy is any function mapping
from the states to the actions so this
is one policy that says are in this
state you know this policy tells you in
this state for one go north which is
actually pretty bad thing to do right
it's take you to the minus one reward so
this is not a great policy but but just
just a policy and V PI for this policy
don't worry too much about the specific
numbers but yo if you look at this
policy you see that from this set of
states it's pretty efficient at getting
you to the really bad reward and from
this set of states is pretty efficient
at getting you to the good reward right
what's some mixing because of their
noise in the robotic veering off to the
side and so you know these numbers are
all negative and those numbers are at
least somewhat positive right so but so
V PI is just um if you start from say
this state from the state 1 1 on
expectation you're expected some of this
counter Wars will be negative
point-eight
so that's what be pious
no the following equation governs the
value function it's called it's called a
bellman equation and this is that your
expected payoff at a given stage is the
reward that you receive plus a discount
factor times the future rewards so let
me let me actually explain the intuition
behind is right which is that let's say
you start off at some state as 0 right
so oh and again let's let's say s is
equal to s 0 so V PI of s it is equal to
well just for your robots waking up in
that I'm gonna add to it in a second ok
but just for the sake just for this for
the fact that your robot woke up in this
state s you get the immediate you get it
reward RF as zero right away just as
something's called this is also called
the immediate reward because you know
just for the for the good fortune of bad
fortune of starting off in this state
the robot gets a reward right away this
is called the immediate reward and then
it will take some action and get to some
new stage s1 well receive you know gamma
times the reward of s1 and then right
and then I'll get some future reward at
the next step and so on and just to
flesh out the definition the value
function V PI is really this given that
you execute the policy PI and s0 equals
s right and you start off in the same as
zero now what I'm going to do is we
write this part of the equation a little
bit I'm going to factor out I'm just
going to take the rest of this and
factor out one factor of gamma so let me
put parentheses around this right and
just take out gamma there okay so I'm
just you know taking this PVC this was
gamma squared right but I think the
parentheses here I'm just taking out one
factor of gamma that multiplies in the
restaurant equation okay does any sense
no so as in gamma R of s 1 plus gamma
squared R of s 2 equals gamma R times R
of s 1 ok so that's that's what I did
down there right just factor out 1 1
factor of gamma and so this is the the
value of state s is the immediate reward
plus gamma times the expected future
rewards right so this the expected value
of this is really V PI of s 1 right so
this and
so the second term here this is the
expected future rewards so pelvis
equation says that the value of a state
the value the expected total payoff you
get if your robot wakes up in the state
s is the immediate reward plus gamma
times the expected future rewards okay
right and and this thing under you know
above the curly braces is really asking
if you rope out wakes up at the state s1
and excuse PI what is the expected total
payoff right and this what if you robot
wakes I'm gonna state s1 then you know
take an action get us to take an
actually get to s3 and this is the sum
of this counter war sort of it starts
off with the state s1 okay so this base
on this you can write out
well these justify Bellman's equations
which is oh and and the mapping from
this equation to this equation
all right the mapping from the equation
on top to the equation that bottom is
that s maps to s 0 and s prime master s
1 right and and so if we have that be PI
of s equals so the value of state s is
our Vespas V PI of s prime where this is
s 0 and this is s 1 and and in the
notation of MDP if you want to write a
long sequence of States we tend to use s
0 s 1 s 2 s 3 and s 4 and so on but if
you have want to look at just the
current state and the state you get 2
after 1 times that we tend to use s and
s prime for that so that's why this is
mapping between these two pieces
notation so s prime is say you get two
after one step well let's see one is s
prime drawn from write this so does the
state s prime or s 1 is the state you
get to after 1 time step so what is what
is the distribution to s prime is drawn
from s prime is drawn from P of what
okay PFS cool because in state s you
will take action a equals PI of s right
so we're executing the policy pi so that
means that when you're in the state s
you're going to take the action a given
by PI of s goes PI of s tells you please
take this action a when you're in state
s and so s prime is drawn from P of s a
where a is equal to PI of s right
because the cause that's the action you
took which is why s Prime the state you
get to after one time step is drawn from
the distribution s PI of s
so putting all that together that's why
well I just write the other game where
belma's equations which is V PI of s
equals R of s plus the discount factor
times the expected value of V PI of s
prime and so this term here is just some
of the S prime be s PI of s be PI of s
Prime okay so that underlying term I
guess is this underlying term here um
now notice that this gives you a linear
system of equations for actually solving
for the value function so let's say I
give you a policy it could be a good
policy could be a bad policy and you
want to solve the PI of s what this does
is if you think of the PI of s as the
unknowns you're trying to solve for
given PI write these equations
these are the pelvis equations defines a
linear system of equations in terms of
the PI of s as the very values to be
solved for so maybe here's a here's a
specific example let's take the state v1
right so this is the state 3 1 what this
what balance equation this tells us is
the PI of the state 3 comma 1 is equal
to the mediator what you get at the
state 3 1 plus the discount factor times
well some of s prime PS PI of s be PI of
s prime right so oh and let's say that
PI of 3 1 is no so let's see try to go
north if you try to go north from the
state then you have a 0.8 chance of
getting to 3/2 plus a 0.1 chance of
veering left plus 0.1 chance of veering
right so that's what balance equation
says about these values right and if
your goal is to solve for the value
function then these things I'm just
circling in purple are the unknown
variables
and if you have eleven states like in
our MDP then this gives you a system of
eleven linear equations with eleven
unknowns and so using server linear
algebra solver you can solve explicitly
for the value of these eleven unknowns
so they way you it so let's say give you
a policy PI you know any policy PI the
way you can solve for the value function
is create an eleven dimensional vector
with V PI of you know one one V PI of 1
2 and so on down to the PI of whether is
the last thing you have eleven state so
V PI of easy or whatever for three right
so if you want to solve for those eleven
numbers I wrote up just in terms of
defining V PI what you can do is I'll
give you a policy PI you can then
construct an eleven dimensional vector
you know 11 dimensional vector of
unknown values that you want to solve
for and balanced equations for each of
the eleven states for each of the eleven
states you could plug in on the left
hand side just gives you one equation
for how one of the values is determined
as a linear function of a few other of
the values in this vector okay and so
what this does is it sets up a linear
system of equations with eleven
variables in eleven unknowns right and
using a linear algebra solver you you
will be able to solve this linear system
of equations does make sense okay all
right and so this works so lousy about
this piece yeah if you have eleven
states you know it takes this takes
almost it takes almost no time right and
the computer to solve and then this is
an eleven equation so that's how you
would actually get those values if you
have a called on to solve for V pi okay
actually the there why just say make
sense raise your hand if what I just
explained made sense like cool awesome
thing
all right good
so moving on our roadmap will define V
PI let's now define V Star so so V Star
is the optimal value function and we'll
define it as V star of s equals max
overall policies PI of V PI one of the
slightly confusing things about
reinforced with an in terminology is
that there two types of value function
there's value function for a given
policy PI and that's the optimal value
function V star so both of these are
called value functions but one is a
value function for a specific policy
could be a great policy could be
terrible policy could be also policy the
other is V star which is the optimal
optimal value function so V Star is
defined as locally value for you know
any look across all of the possible
policies you could have all four to
eleven where all the company totally
large number of possible policy so
there's MVP and these star affairs is
well let's just take the max which is of
all the possible of all the policies you
know anyone could implement of all the
possible policies let's take the value
of the best possible policy for that
state so that's V star okay that's the
all Tolle also a value function and it
turns out that
there is a different version of bellman
equations for this and again there's a
balance equations for be pi/4 value of a
policy and then there's a different
version of bellman equations for the
optimal value function right so just as
the two versions of value functions
there are two versions of balance
equations but let me just write this out
hopefully this will make sense actually
let's think this through so let's say
you start off your robot in a state s
what is the best possible expected some
of this counselor was what's the best
possible payoff it again right well just
for the privilege of waking up in state
s the robot will receive an immediate
what R of s and then it has to take some
action and after taking some action it
will get to some other state as a prime
you know and after some other state s
prime it will receive future expected
rewards v-star best prime and we have to
discount that by camera right so so well
the state s prime was arrived at by
you're taking some action a from the
initial state and so whatever the action
is you know but if you take action a so
if you take an action a in the state s
then your total payoff will be expected
total payoff will be the immediate
reward plus gamma times the expected
value of the future payoff but what is
the action a that we should plug in here
right
well the optimal action to take in the
MDP
is whatever action maximizes your
expected total payoff maximize you
expected some rewards which is why the
action you want to plug in is just
whatever action a maximizes that okay so
this is um Domus equations for the
optimal value function which says that
the best possible expected total payoff
you could receive starting from state s
is the immediate reward R of s plus max
over all possible actions of whatever
action allows you to maximize you know
your expected total payoff expect a
future payoff
okay so this is the expected future
payoff expected future reward now based
on the argument we just went through
this allows us to figure out how to
compute PI star of s as well right which
is let's say let's say we have a way of
computing V star of s right we don't yet
but let's say I tell you what does V
Sarvis and then I'll see you you know
what is the action you should take in a
given stage so remember PI spy star of
PI star is going to auto policy and so
what should PI star vests be right which
is let's say let's say we're we're
computing V Star and I now ask you hey
my robots in state s what is the best
action I should take from the state s
right then how do I decide what action
to take in the state yes
well what would think is the best action
to take from this state and the answer
is almost given in the equation of oh
yeah
yeah cool awesome right so the best
action to take and state us and best
means maximizing expected total payoff
but the option that maximizes your
expenses total payoff is you know well
whatever action we were choosing a up
here and so it's just long max over a
and because gamma is just a constant
that doesn't affect the arcmap usually
we just we just eliminate that this is
just a positive number right so this
gives us the strategy we will use for
finding the also policy for an MVP which
is we're going to find a way to compute
V Star of S which we don't have a way of
doing yet rightly star was defined as a
max over combinatorially or
exponentially large number policies so
we don't have way of computing piece not
yet but if we can find a way to compute
B star then you know using this equation
certainly just scratch themself using
this equation gives you a way for every
state of every state s pretty
efficiently computes this augment and
therefore figure out what is the optimal
action for every state
all right so all right so just practice
with confusing notation all right let's
see if you understand this equation I'm
just claiming this I'm not proving this
but for every state as V Star of s
equals G of Pi star of s is greater than
a PI of s all right for every policy
Pyne every state s okay so I hope this
equation makes sense this is what I'm
claiming I didn't prove this one
claiming is that the October value for
state s is this is the optimal value
function on the left this is the value
function for pi star so this is this is
about optimal value function this is the
value function for a specific policy PI
where the policy PI happens to be PI
star and so what I'm claiming here is
that what what I'm writing here is that
the optimal value for state s is equal
to the value function for PI star
applied to the state s and this is great
sin equal to V PI of s for any other
policy by
so the strategy you can use for finding
for also policy is one v V star to you
know use the R max equation to find pi
star okay and so what we're going to do
is well step to write we know how to do
from the optimized equation so what
we're gonna do is top an algorithm for
actually computing visa because if you
can compute V song then this equation
helps allows you to pretty quickly find
the optimal action for every state
so um so value iteration is as an album
you can use to to find V star so let me
just write out the algorithm so in the
value iteration algorithm you initialize
the estimated value of every state to
zero and then you update these estimated
values using Bellman's equations and
this is the optimal value function the V
star version of Bellman's equations and
so to be concrete about how you
implement this you have um inferencing
this right if you're implying didn't
Python what you would do is create an 11
dimensional vector to store all the
values of V of s so you create a you
know 11 dimensional vector right that
that represents V of 1 1 V of 1 2 you
know down to V over 4 3 right so this is
um 11 dimensional vector corresponding
to the 11 states oh I'm sorry I should
wait did I say 11 where 10 stays in the
MTB don't we wait yes we have 10 sees
I've been saying 11 all along sorry okay
10 oh yes you're right sorry yes okay
sorry
so 11 state MDP serie credit initial
credit 11 dimensional vector and
initialize all of these values to 0 and
then you will repeatedly update the
estimated value of every state according
to balance equations right and so
they're there they're actually two ways
to interpret this and similar to some of
the gradient descent right we've written
out you know a gradient descent rule for
updating the theta the the vector
parameters theta and what you do is you
know and you have and what you do is you
update all of the components of theta
simultaneously right and so that's
called a synchronous update in gradient
descent so one way to so the way you
would update this equation in what's
called a synchronous update
will behave you compute the right hand
side for all 11 states and then you
simultaneously overwrite all 11 values
at the same time and then you compute
all 11 values for the right hand side
and then you're simultaneously update
all 11 values okay the alternative would
be an asynchronous update and then a
synchronous update what you do is you
compute V f11 right and the value of V
of 1 1 depends on some of the other
values on the right hand side right but
in a synchronous update you compute V of
1 1 and then you would overwrite this
value first and then you use that
equation to compute V of 1 2 and then
you update this and then you update
these one at a time and the difference
between synchronous and asynchronous is
you know if you're using asynchronous
update by the time you're using V or 4/3
which depends on some of the earlier
values you'd be using a new and refresh
value of some of the earlier values on
your list ok it turns out that value
iteration works fine with either
synchronous up these or asynchronous
updates but further but because it
vectorized is better because you can use
more efficient matrix operations most
people use the synchronous update but it
turns out that the algorithm will work
whether using is synchronous or
asynchronous update sorry is unless
unless otherwise you know stated you
should usually assume that when I talk
about validation I'm referring to
synchronous update where you compute all
the values all 11 values using the and
then update all 11 values at the same
time ok is there a question just now so
my that yeah
yeah yes so I think they're there yes so
how do you represent the absorbing state
the sink say we go to plus or minus one
day the world ends in this framework one
way to code that up would be to say that
the state has inference from that to any
other state is zero that's one way to
that that would work another way would
be less done less often maybe
mathematical but clean up and not how
people tend to do this it would be to
take your let me say MDP and then create
at all state and the tall state always
goes back to itself with no further than
what so do both both of these would give
you the same result though mat batty is
pretty more convenient to just set you
know PFF say s prime equals 0 for all
other states it's not quite safe hasn't
already but that that will give you the
ranch as well all right cool
so just as a point of notation if you're
using synchronous updates you can think
of this as taking the old value function
o estimate right and using it to compute
the new estimates so this this you know
assuming the synchronous update you have
some previous 11 dimensional vector with
your estimate of the value from the
previous iteration and after doing one
iteration of this you have a new set of
estimate so one step of this algorithm
is sometimes called via bellman back of
operator and so where you update the
equals
b.o.b right where we're now he is a 11
dimensional vector so you have an O the
leverage the original vector compute the
bellmen backup operator was just that
equation there and update the according
to B and so one thing that you see in
the problem set is is showing that this
will make a BFS
condors to be stock so it turns out that
okay so it turns out that you can prove
and you see more details that this is a
problem set that by repeatedly enforcing
Bellman's equations that this equate
this this algorithm will cause your
vector of eleven value so cause V to
converge to the optimal value function V
star okay and more details you see the
homework Illumina lecture notes and it
turns out this algorithm actually
converges quite quickly right so to give
you a flavor I think that uh with the
discount factor if the discount factor
is 0.99 it turns out that you can show
that the error reduces your by a factor
of point 99 on every iteration and so V
actually converges quite quickly
dramatically quickly if you are
exponentially quickly to the October
value function V Star and service you
know the discount factor is 0.99 there
was like a few where behind your
iterations there are a few hundred
iterations v p-- would be very close to
be stock okay and and the discount
factors point nine then with just you
know ten or few dozens of innovations
would be very close to be saw so this
outer measure converges quite quickly to
be stock
so let's see
[Applause]
so just to put everything together if
you if you run value iteration on debt
MDP
you end up with this so this is B star
so solicited eleven numbers telling you
what is the optimal expected payoff for
starting off in into the eleven possible
states and so I had previously said I
think I said last week of the week
before Thanksgiving that this is the
optimal policy so you know let's just
use as a case study how you compute the
optimal action for that state given this
v-star
all right well what you do is you
actually just use this equation and so
if you were to go Wes then if you were
to compute I guess this term sum of s
prime Wetzel left I guess right P of si
s prime B star of s prime is equal to if
you were to go west you have a
right so if you're in this state and if
you attempt to go left then there's a
point a chance you end up there with a
visa 0.75 there's a point 1 chance you
know if you try to go left this point
one chance you veer off to the north and
have a 0.69 and then there's a point 1
chance that you actually go south and
bounce off the wall and end up with 0.71
and so do you expected future rewards
expected future payoff given this
equation is that if you tend to go Wes
you end up with 0.7 for 0 as expected
future rewards whereas you were to go
north if you do a similar computation
you know so 0.8 times point 6 9 plus
point 1 times 175 plus point 1 times 24
9 the appropriate way to the average you
find that is equal to 0.67 6 which is
why the expected future rewards so if
you go Wes it'll know left is 0.74 0
which is quite a bit higher than if you
go north which is why we can conclude
based on this low calculation that the
also policy is to go left at that state
and then really and technically you
check north south east and west and make
sure that going west gives a high reward
and that's how you can conclude that
going west is actually the better action
at this state okay so that's value
iteration and based on this if you are
given an MDP you can implement this
solve a V Star and be able to compute PI
sock
a few more things I'll go over but
before I move on let me check are there
any questions
oh sure yep Islamic state is always
finite so in what we're discussing so
far yes but what we'll see on Wednesday
is how to generalize this framework well
looted this a little bit later but it
turns out if you have a continuous state
MDP one of the things that's often done
i guess is to discretize into finite
number of states but then there are also
some other versions of you know value
duration that applies directly to
continuous states as well so what I
described is an algorithm called value
iteration the other on a common sort of
textbook algorithm for solving for MVPs
is called policy iteration and let me
just well just write out what the
algorithm is so here's the algorithm
which is um you know initialize PI
randomly
okay so let's see what this algorithm
does so let's talk about pros and cons
evaluation versus policy aeration a
little bit in policy iteration instead
of solving for the optimal policy vsauce
in that the iteration a focus of
attention was v star right where you
know you do a lot of work to try to find
the value function and then once you
solve for v song you then figure out the
best policy in policy iteration the
focus of attention is on the policy pi
rather than the value function and so
initialize pi randomly so that means for
each of the 11 states pick a random
action it's a random initial time and
then we're going to repeatedly carry out
these two steps the first step is solve
for the value function for the policy pi
right I remember for V PI this was a
linear system of equations right with
eleven variables with eleven unknowns in
it was a linear system of eleven
equations with eleven unknowns and so
using a sort of linear algebra solver or
a linear equation solver given a fixed
policy PI you could just you know at the
cost of inverting a matrix roughly right
you can solve for you can solve for all
of these eleven values and so in policy
iteration you would you know use a
linear solver to solve for the optimal
value function for this policy pi that
we just randomly initialized and then
set V to be the value function for that
policy okay and so this is done quite
efficiently with a linear solver and
then the second step of policy duration
is pretend that V is the optimal value
function and update PI of s you know
using the balanced equations for the
octal value function very updated as you
saw right how do you update the higher
best
and then you iterate and then given a
new policy you then solve that linear
system equations for your new policy PI
to get a new B PI and you keep on
iterating these two steps until
converges ok yeah yep yes that's right
so in in value yeah yeah so in in value
iteration in value iteration think
evaluator HS waiting to the end to
compute PI of s very soft wavy stop
first and compute PI of s whereas in
policy iteration we're coming up with a
new policy on every single iteration
okay so um pros and cons of poly and it
turns out that this algorithm will also
converge to the optimal policy pros and
cons of policy iteration versus
valuation policy duration requires
solving this linear system of equations
in order to get B PI and so it turns out
that if you have a relatively small
state space like if you have 11 states
is really easy to solve a linear system
of equations
you know if 11 equations in order to get
V PI and so if you're relatively small
set of states like eleven states are
really anything you know like a few
hundred States policy raishin we're
quite quickly but if you have a
relatively large set of states you know
like ten thousand stays or a million
states then this step would be much
slower at least if you do it right by
solving the system of equations and then
I would favor a value iteration over
policy iterations so for larger problems
usually value iteration will usually I
would use value iteration because
solving this linear system of equations
you know this is pretty expensive if
it's a good million by there's a million
equations a million unknowns that's
quite expensive
but if in Lebanon stays in Lebanon knows
there's very small system equations and
then one one other pros and cons one of
the difference that's maybe maybe more
academic than practical but it turns out
that if you use value iteration V will
converge to what V Star but they won't
ever get to exactly the star right so
just as if you apply gradient descent
for linear regression gradient descent
gets closer and closer and closer to the
global optimum but it never you know
guess exactly the global optimum it just
gets really really close really fast
actually great in the sand actually
turns out as an topically converges
geometrically quickly really quickly
right but but never quite gets you know
definitively to the optimal to the one
optimal value whereas you saw using
normals equations it just jump straight
to the optimal value and there's no you
know converging slowly and so value
duration converges to or V star but it
doesn't ever end up at exactly the value
V star this difference may be a bit
epidemic because in practice it doesn't
matter right but in policy iteration if
you innovate this algorithm then after a
finite number of iterations this album
will stop changing meaning that after
certain number of iterations PI of s
would just not change anymore right so
you find higher best update the value
function and then after another
iteration when you take these out maxes
you end up with exactly the same policy
and so this just salsa the also a value
and the also policy and they just you
know it doesn't converge it doesn't does
converge to what the also value it just
gets the optimal value when it when it
converges okay so I think in practice I
actually see value iteration use much
more
because solving this linear equations
gets expensive you know if you have a
large estate space but valuation it's
usually policy I see valuation use much
more but if you have a small problem you
know I think you could also use policy
iteration which might converse a little
bit faster if you have a small problem
so the last thing is kind of putting it
together right and what if you don't
know so it turns out that when you apply
this to a practical problem you know in
robotics right one common scenario you
run into is if you do not know what is P
of Si if you don't know the state
transition probabilities right so when
we built the MDP we said well let's say
the robots if you go off you know has a
point a chance a great knife and a point
one chance of varying off so therefore
rights if you actually the game this is
a very simplified robot but if you build
a actual robot to build a you know
helicopter or whatever play play chess
against an opponent the state-transition
properties are often not known in
advance and so in many MVP
implementations you need to estimate
this from data and so the workflow of
many many reinforcement learning
projects will be that you will have some
policy and have the robot run around you
know just have a robot run around a maze
and counter of all the times you had to
take the action north how often did it
actually go know of and how often do
they fear often left or right right so
you use those statistics as state
transition probabilities so let me just
write this out so you estimate so after
you know taking maybe a random policy to
take some policy execute some policy in
the MD
for a while and then you would estimate
this from data and so the obvious
formula would be SVP of SAS prime to be
number of times took action a and state
s and got to s Prime and divide that by
the number of times you took action
that's right so TFSAs prime estimate
there's actually a massive likely
estimate when you look at the number of
times you took action in state s and
that was the fraction of times you got
to this day that's prime right or 1 over
s in a common you know heuristic is if
you've never taken this action in just a
before if you if the number of times you
try action in state as a zero so you've
never tried this action this state so
you have no idea what's gonna do then
just assume that the state transition
probability is 1 over 11 right then
you're randomly takes you to endlessly
so this would be rather common
heuristics that people use when
implementing reports or learning
algorithms and it turns out that you can
use the paths moving for this if you
wish but you don't have to because so
you're in the past moving right Sofia
you know adds one to the numerator and
and 11 to the denominator would be if
you were to use Laplace smoothing which
a voice the problems of zero over zeroes
as well but it turns out that unlike the
naive Bayes algorithm these solvers MDPs
are not that sensitive to 0 values so if
if one your estimates are probably is
zero you know unlike naive Bayes we're
having a zero probability was very
problematic
for the classifications made by naive
Bayes it turns out that MDP solvers
including evaluation and policy duration
they do not give sort of nonsensical /
horrible results just because of a few
probabilities are exactly zero and so in
practice you know you can use the
Laplace moving if you wish but because
the reinforcement learning algorithms
don't don't perform that badly of these
estimates are often well below zero in
practice the past moving is not commonly
unison what I just wrote is it's more
common so to put it together
if I give you a robot and ask you to
implement a MTP solver to find a good
policy for this robot what you would do
is the following take actions respect to
some policy PI to get experience in the
MDP so go ahead and let your robot loose
and have it ask you some policy for a
while and then update estimates of PFS a
based on the observations where the
robot goes when takes different states
update update SMS app EFSA solve Velma's
equation using value iteration
to get V and then I'll update so this is
the value generation way of putting it
together if you want to plug in policy
innovation instead and just that that's
also okay but so if you actually get a
robot you know right if you actually get
a robot where you do not know in advance
the state transition probabilities then
this is what you would do in order to
enter in a few times I guess right
repeatedly finally find a final policy
given your carbon estimate of the state
transition probabilities get some
experience update your S Pen is finally
your policy and kind of repeat this
process until hopefully converges to
good policy
now just to add more color more richness
to this we usually think of we usually
think of the reward function as being
given right as part of the problem
specification but sometimes you see that
the reward function may be unknown and
so for example if you're building a
stock trading application and the reward
is the returns on a certain day it may
not be a function of the statement may
be a little bit random or if you're
robots is you know running around but
depend on where it goes it may hit
different bumps in the road and you want
to give her the penalty every time it
hits a bump build self-driving car right
and every time it hits a bump hits a
pothole you give the negative reward
then sometimes the rewards are random
function of the environment and so
sometimes you can also estimate the
expected value of a reward but but in
some applications of the reward is the
random function the state then this
process allows you to also estimate the
expected value the reward from every
state and then running this more oq2
okay
yeah yep cool great question so let me
let me talk about exploration right so
it turns out that um this one so it
turns out this algorithm will work okay
for some problems but there's one other
again to add richness to this there's
one other issue that this is not solving
which is the exploration problem and
possible earnings sometimes you hear the
term exploration versus exploitation
which is let me use a different MVP
example which is um if your robot you
know starts off here and if there is a
plus-one reward here right and maybe a
+10 the water here if just by chance
doing the first time you run the robot
it happens to find its way to the +1
then if you run this algorithm it may
figure out that going to the +1 is a
good way right over we're giving a
discount factor does a feel so in charge
of minus 0.02 on every step so if just
by chance your robot happens to find
this way to the +1 the first few times
you run this algorithm then this
algorithm is yourself locally greedy
right
it may figure out that this is a great
way to get to +1 reward and in the world
ends it stops getting these minus 0.02
surcharges but fuel and so this
particular algorithm may converge to a
bad you know kind of local optima where
it's always heading to the +1 and as it
has a +1 sometimes OVR randomly right
and you look a little bit more
experienced in the right half of the
state space and end up with pretty good
estimate of what happens in the right
of the state space and and it may never
find this hard to define +10 pilot goat
over on the lower left okay so this
problem is sometimes called actually
wrong it is called the exploration
versus exploitation problem which is
when you're acting on an MDP you know
how aggressively or how greedy should
you be at just taking actions to
maximize your rewards and so the average
strive is relatively greedy meaning that
is taking your best estimate of the
state transition probabilities and
rewards and it's just taking whatever
actions and this is really saying you
know pick the policy that maximizes your
current estimate of the expected rewards
and it's just acting greedily meaning on
every step is just executing the policy
that it thing's allows it to maximize
the expected payoff and what this album
does not do at all is explore which is
the process of taking actions that may
appear less optimal at the outset such
as if the robot hasn't seen this +10
reward doesn't know how we get there
maybe it should you know just try going
left a couple times just for the heck of
it right to see what happens because
even if it seems less even if going left
from the perspective of the current
state of the knowledge robot maybe if it
try some new things has never tried
before maybe you'll find a new pot of
gold okay so this is called the
exploration versus exploitation
trade-off oh and this is actually not
just an academic problem it turns out
that some of the large online web
advertising platforms have the same
problem as well again I I've mixed
feelings about the advertising business
it's very lucrative and it causes other
problems as well but but it turns out
that for something large online
platforms you know when when an
advertiser starts selling a new ad or
you're posting a new ad on one of the
large online ad platforms the ad
platform does not know who is most
likely to click on this ad
and so pure explore in pure exploitation
boy exploitation is such horrible
conversation especially terrible on my
lap that one's the technical term no
there's no the social term when uses in
the context but the pure you know
reinforcement learning sense
exploitation policy not not the other
even more horrible sense of exploitation
would be to always just show you show
show users the ads that you know they
are most likely to click on to drive
short-term revenues who's gonna just
show people the atom also you click on
to actual turn revenue whereas an
exploration for policy for a large you
know something large online ad platforms
it's a show people some ads that may not
be what we think you're most likely to
click on in this moment in time but by
showing you that ad or by showing the
pool of users an ad that you might be
less like quick on maybe we'll learn
more about your interests and that
increases the effectiveness of these
large of these ad platforms that finding
more relevant ads for example I don't
know purview no I I guess uh they're
probably know a participants for maja
slanders as I know but if the large
online ad platforms don't know that I'm
actually pretty interested in Mars
Landers if it shows me an ad for Mars
Lander which I don't think such a thing
exists right and I click on it didn't
learn that showing me as the Mars
Landers great thing right
or some other thing that I mean no no
interesting so this is actually a real
problem there are some of the large
online ad platforms actually do
explicitly consider exploration versus
exploitation and make sure that
sometimes it shows as that may not be
the most likely you click on but you
know allows you to gather information to
then be better situated to figure out
where the future rewards to be better
position to learn how to mash it's not
just that you but other users like you
sorry okay but so in order to make sure
they're reinforcement learning algorithm
explores as exploits a common
modification to this would be tick
instead of taking actions respect to pie
you may have a zero point nine chance
respective high and 0pi one chance take
an action randomly okay and so this
particular exploration policy is called
epsilon greedy we're on every time step
and on every time step you toss a biased
coin but on every time step let's say
90% of the chance you execute whatever
you think is a current best policy and
with 10% chance you just take a random
action and this type of exploration
policy increases the odds that you know
every now and then maybe just by chance
right it'll find this way to the plus 10
polyp goals and learning state
transition probabilities and and and
then eventually end up exploring the
state space more thoroughly okay this is
called epsilon greedy exploration and
there's a little bit of a misnomer I
think so in in in the way we think of
epsilon we D epsilon is on say 0.1 is
the chance of taking a random action
instead of the greedy action this
algorithm it's has always been a little
bit strangely named because if 0.1 is
actually the chance of you're acting
randomly right so epsilon greedy it
sounds like you're being greedy point
one of the time but but you're actually
taking actions randomly upon one at a
time so epsilon greediest actually may
be one minus Epsilon greedy so this name
has always been a little bit off but
that's what that's that's that's how
people use this term epsilon greedy
exploration means epsilon at the time
which is a hyper parameter which is the
parameter the algorithm you act randomly
into instead of going to what you think
is the best policy
okay and it turns out that if you
implement this algorithm with epsilon
greedy exploration then this this
algorithm will converge to the optimal
policy for any discrete state MVP right
sometimes didn't take a long time
because you know if there's a if it
takes a long time to randomly find plus
ten
it could take a long time before
randomly stumbles upon 2 plus 10
particles but this algorithm women with
an exploration policy will converge to
the optimal what will converge the
optimal policy for any MDP oh yeah yes
sir right she always keep us on constant
or she view dilation Epsilon so yes
there are there are many heuristics for
how to explore one reasonable thing to
do would be start with a large value of
epsilon and it's low e-string
another common heuristic would be um
there's a different type of exploration
called Bo's from the exploration we can
look up if you want which is uh if you
think that the value of going off is you
know 10 and the value of going solvus 1
then there's such a huge difference that
you should bias your action to are going
to the bigger result the bigger reward
and then you could have the probability
be e to the value basically right time
divided times the scaling factor right
so that's called bozeman exploration
where instead of having a 10% chance of
taking action completely at random you
could just you know have a very strong
bias to heading toward the higher values
but also have some probability to go
into lower values but where the exact
probability depends on the different
values so the another pair either I
think I've saw greenie I feel like I see
this use the most often for these types
of MVPs and then Boltzmann exploration
which is why just like this also use
just two more questions you'd wrap up
good
oh yes you give her one for reaching say
she has never seen before
yes there's a fascinating line of
research called intrinsic reinforcement
learning I mean we started by sitting
the same if you google for intrinsic
intrinsic motivation you find some
research papers on and then there was
some recent fall on work I think by deep
line or some of the groups but intrinsic
motivation is to turn to Google where
you reward reinforcement learning
algorithm for finding new things about
the world oh I see right
how often should on the Asha issue you
take before updating pi um
there's no how to do it as frequently as
possible in the if you're doing this
with a real robot what you know I've
seen is this is sometimes going to a
physical robot and so you know I don't
know one of five helicopters you've gone
to the view for a day collect all data
and then go back to the lab and evening
and rerun the algorithms but if there's
no barrier to running this all the time
then it doesn't hurt the performance
they're just running as beautiful as you
can all right that's it for basis of MDP
on Wednesday we'll continue with
generalizing all these to continuous
state ok let's break loose your
Wednesday